en este vídeo quiero profundizar en el
concepto del ingreso del producto
marginal quiero ver como esta curva que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado realmente es
una curva de beneficio marginal para
nuestro negocio que era un lavado de
autos después con esto vamos a ver qué
nos puede decir cuál es la cantidad
óptima de trabajadores que tenemos que
contratar pero bueno empecemos viendo
por qué es una curva de beneficio
marginal porque cada uno de estos puntos
nos dan el beneficio adicional que
obtiene la empresa pues bueno vamos a
empezar con este punto de acá a este
punto moradito cuando pasamos de tener
de 0 a 1 trabajadores este inicio de acá
lo podemos pensar como el ingreso
promedio marginal que nos está dando los
trabajadores de esta región de acá o sea
aquí tenemos una información discreta 0
1 2 3 4 así trabajadores pero podemos
pensar no sé en una veinteava parte en
una veinteava parte del trabajador pues
pensando en un trabajador que
contratamos y que viene digamos cada
cada 20 días o en un trabajador que
trabaja sólo tres minutos en cada hora o
así lo cual podría ser un poco en
práctico pero la cosa es que hay formas
de hacer esta curva continua entonces
este punto morado en vez de pensarlo
como un punto discreto podemos pensarlo
como el promedio del ingreso del
producto marginal que nos dan los
trabajadores en esta región de acá muy
bien entonces con eso en mente cómo le
podemos hacer para calcular cuánto
beneficio nos da todo este trabajador
pues lo que podemos hacer es obtener un
área a qué me refiero con esto pues me
voy a fijar en el rectángulo que pasa
por aquí que pasa por este punto y llega
hasta el 1
ba enter entonces cómo le hacemos para
obtener el beneficio que obtenemos pues
básicamente es multiplicar el beneficio
que nos da este trabajador este
trabajador adicional por el trabajador
adicional es decir el beneficio marginal
que estamos obteniendo al pasar le voy a
poner así al pasar de 0 a 1
el beneficio marginal que estamos
obteniendo es multiplicar este 1 este 1
por este 250 por este promedio en
ingreso de producto marginal entonces
aquí nos da un beneficio de 250 pesos
ahora a lo mejor necesita es un poco de
cálculo para para ver lo que te voy a
decir pero en realidad eso es lo mismo
que obtener el área debajo de la línea
que dibuje de la línea que unía a los
puntos este triángulo de acá se compensa
con este triangulito de acá y entonces
el área de este rectángulo es la misma
que el área este bueno de este como
trapecio sí que se hace con el
triangulito de aquí y de acá muy bien de
manera similar
este segundo punto lo voy a poner con el
color que estaba usando creo que este
azul este segundo punto que nos dice nos
dice que al pasar de 12 trabajadores
obtenemos un beneficio adicional de 200
que también podemos pensarlo como el
área de este rectángulo de este
rectángulo de acá lo voy a pintar así
que son 200 adicionales 200 de beneficio
marginal adicional una vez más podemos
repetir el argumento por acá
estos son 150
acá tenemos y si este azul no creo que
es este otro azul acá tenemos un
beneficio marginal de 100 de 100 y
finalmente este puntito nos dice que
tenemos un beneficio marginal de 50
entonces lo interesante es que podemos
pensar que este esta curva de ingreso
del producto marginal en beneficio
marginal bien digo no se nota tanto
porque estamos multiplicando por uno sí
pero realmente esta multiplicación por
uno pues podría cambiar con otro tipo de
tablas pan ok entonces esta curva es
también una curva de beneficio marginal
y ya habíamos platicado cómo es es una
curva de demanda muy bien pero ahora
cómo le podemos hacer para saber cuántos
trabajadores contratar pues realmente
todavía no tenemos toda la información
necesaria todavía tenemos que saber algo
más es muy ponerle aquí el morado
todavía tenemos que saber algo más
tenemos que saber cuál es el precio que
cobran los trabajadores por por trabajar
en nuestra empresa o sea si cobran muy
poquito entonces nos conviene contratar
a muchos y cobran muchos nos conviene
contratar a poquitos dependiendo de
ciertas cosas entonces para esto nada
más déjame hacer una aclaración
y vamos a ponerle que esta empresa de
este lavado de autos también es
competitivo le voy a poner competitivo
competitivo pero ahora como comprador o
como como como parte que adquiere
trabajo o sea acá arriba habíamos dicho
que era competitivo en el mercado de
lavados de auto y en el mercado de
lavados de auto
esto es importante dejan de escribirlo
para que quede muy claro
o sea cuando estamos hablando del
mercado de lavado de autos de autos la
empresa está ofertando es decir es el
vendedor vendedor y lo primero que
dijimos es que era competitivo aquí pero
ahora además estamos diciendo que en el
mercado laboral laboral también es
competitivo o sea no es un comprador muy
muy poderoso en el mercado laboral ahora
es un comprador
comprador y está compitiendo con otros
compradores con otras empresas de
lavados de auto para contratar este
mercado laboral a lo mejor aquí debería
ser un pequeño paréntesis ya que está un
poco yéndose por la tangente pero pero
es importante decirlo o sea estoy aquí
es ser competitivo pero ser no
competitivo voy a poner aquí no
competitivo pues tenemos ciertos
términos verdad ya platicamos como un
vendedor que no es competitivo que tiene
acaparado una gran cantidad de mercado y
es muy importante se le conoce como que
está en un monopolio
monopolio entonces estoy acá no se
conoce un común monopolio de compra hay
una palabra específica para hacer un
gran comprador que tiene una influencia
muy grande en el mercado y se le conoce
como monopsonio monopsonio y te lo digo
para que esta palabra no te agarre por
sorpresa si a lo mejor en la próxima
reunión tu tío dije hada
bimbo eres un mono son yo o lo que sea
pero es la palabra otra vez viene del
grey del griego y significa gran
comprador bueno entonces regresando a lo
que estábamos te preguntarás por qué
hice esta aclaración pero la aclaración
simplemente la hice para decir que así
como acá arriba tenemos una tarifa por
lavada de auto de modo similar esto
quiere decir bueno el ser competitivo
quiere decir que esta empresa tiene que
pagar una cierta tarifa estándar que
vamos a suponer que está vamos a ponerle
aquí que la tarifa estándar por hora de
trabajo es de 100 pesos entonces voy a
poner 100 pesos
por hora de trabajo hora de trabajo
claro por trabajador verdad de trabajo
muy bien entonces con esta información
ahora sí ya podemos pensar pues en cuál
es la cantidad de trabajadores que nos
conviene contratar y cómo podemos pensar
esto de acá esta tarifa por ahora en
términos de nuestro modelo pues
justamente lo podemos pensar como un
costo marginal si por el costo que nos
cuesta adquirir un trabajador adicional
otra vez como el mercado es competitivo
los trabajadores adicionales todos
cuestan lo mismo muy bien entonces estoy
acá es un costo adicional entonces
déjame pintar mira acá tenemos cosas
marginales aquí es el ingreso del
producto marginal pero aquí mismo
podemos graficar la curva de costo
marginal cada trabajador adicional nos
da un costo constante de 100 pesos y por
eso todo lo estoy poniendo en una recta
horizontal entonces no importa cuántos
trabajadores tengamos
hay que pagarles y en pesos a cada uno
de ellos entonces ahora sí con esto ya
tenemos toda la información para poder
preguntarnos si tiene sentido adquirir o
no trabajadores entonces ve tiene
sentido adquirir al primer trabajador o
bueno vamos a pensarlo así a la primer
mitad del trabajador pues si la primer
el primer medio trabajador nos va a dar
este beneficio ver a este beneficio
marginal y sólo nos cuesta este costo
marginal entonces pues aquí sí estamos
generando una utilidad una utilidad
económica
esta de acá va que pasa con el segundo
pues vamos a pensar ahora en en este es
en este de acá bueno en el segundo medio
trabajador pues también nos conviene de
hecho o sea nos conviene contratar al
primer trabajador contratar al segundo
trabajador lo voy a pintar observa como
estoy pintando lo abajo de la recta en
la recta blanca entonces también nos
conviene porque esto también es utilidad
económica el tercer trabajador también
nos conviene pero con el cuarto
trabajador pasa algo interesante nos
conviene contratar así totalmente al
cuarto trabajador pues estamos gastando
cien pesos adicionales siempre esos
marginales y estamos obteniendo 100 y
estamos obteniendo 100 pesos marginales
entonces realmente no no tiene mucho
sentido contratar totalmente este cuarto
trabajador porque pues no estamos
obteniendo nada más lo que sí podría
tener sentido es contratar a medio
trabajador qué quiere decir esto pues
contratar a alguien que venga un día sí
y un día no trabajar alguien que sólo
venga medio día o alguien que se dedique
a lavar coches y luego administrar la
caja registradora o algo así entonces
aquí si pudiéramos contratar a ese medio
trabajador estuvieren estaríamos
obteniendo
utilidad económica que está entre esta
curva de aquí y esta curva de acá la de
costo marginal y la de beneficio
marginal muy bien entonces pues esto
está muy padre a partir de esta curva de
demanda
podemos entender cuando conviene o
cuando no conviene contratar un
trabajador adicional y básicamente o sea
si estamos por arriba de esta de este
costo marginal entonces si nos conviene
seguir contratando y después de eso ya
no nos conviene no tiene sentido porque
estamos pagando más de la utilidad
económica que obtenemos